the tower of st. Peter's Church is one
of the best vantage points in Munich
once you've climbed the 306 steps you
can see as far as the Alps weather
permitting the famous Cohen Kia Church
seems close enough to touch and the
implant-- square spreads out far beneath
you several times a day crowds gather in
front of the new Town Hall look up and
get your camera out the glockenspiel is
the main tourist attraction on
marienplatz what's next just set off and
go where your feet take you Munich has
lots of inviting squares the stuff was
even offers a chance to cool off on hot
days anywhere you go in this city you're
right in the middle of the action and
there are lots of cosy corners like here
in the clock bar Fyodor why go into a
museum on such a gorgeous day that just
as beautiful from the outside for the
classically minded with our other
Pinacoteca and if you like it modern the
museum brand hosts all your senses will
be stimulated during a stroll through
the Victorian marked Munich's most
famous farmers market
the Bavarian Kings once lived right
around the corner
here's the former residence you can tour
the inside of course but we'll do that
another time
today we'll stay outside in the Baroque
courtyard garden
[Music]
no summer day in Munich is complete
without a visit to a beer garden for
those on a budget bring your own food
it's allowed you can also relax to some
traditional music like here at the
Chinese tower it doesn't get more
Bavarian than this
you
[Music]